it's about to get really hot down on
Earth because all our oceans suddenly
started to boil
sending steam into the atmosphere at an
alarming rate
why would all this water in the air lead
to setting the planet on fire
how would you feel with all this extra
humidity
and how could this make earth a lot like
one of our sister planets
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the oceans boiled away
Earth's water goes through an amazing
cycle rain runs off into rivers which
carry that water to Oceans Where
eventually it evaporates back up into
the clouds
over and over without fail
the water vapor in our atmosphere is
actually one of the reasons our planet
is habitable it accounts for about half
of the atmosphere's greenhouse warming
effect and there are nearly 38 million
billion gallons up there if it all
condensed and fell back down to Earth At
Once you'd see three centimeters of rain
all around the planet
but soon there could be a lot more Vapor
as we're about to turn up the heat to a
steady boil
as our oceans started heating up the air
would definitely feel sticky hot and
heavy and with such high humidity your
body would struggle to cool down as the
warm moisture would stay on your skin
for longer you could start to suffer
from heat exhaustion
but this wouldn't be the only trouble
we'd now be caught in the middle of a
vicious cycle as this heat spreads
further through the oceans and
atmosphere the atmosphere would be
getting overloaded with water vapor and
this would make things even hotter
the planet would now be absorbing more
energy from the Sun than it can radiate
back into space so we'd be on the verge
of a runaway greenhouse effect and
things would just get hotter
the temperature all over Earth would
start to even out and the poles would
become warmer the polar ice caps and
Mountain glaciers would melt and that
would raise sea levels about 70 meters
flooding would destroy coastal cities
around the world displacing hundreds of
millions of people and all this added
sea water would be adding fuel to the
fire of our increasingly warm
evaporating oceans
at this point all life on Earth would
start to vanish
it would still take several hundred or
even thousands of years before the
oceans are truly boiling away because of
evaporation the boiling point would
increase well that's because of the
higher salt concentration of the
remaining ocean water
but with no stop to the increasing
temperatures all this water would
disappear our planet would turn into a
Barren landscape with new Canyons like
the Mariana Trench extending down
322 kilometers below what used to be sea
level
our atmosphere would be steamy to say
the least
it could be hot enough for wood to
spontaneously combust
but luckily you wouldn't be around
anymore to deal with the forest fires
all over the planet
eventually temperatures could reach or
even surpass the sweltering
482 degrees Celsius heat of one of our
neighbor planets Venus
astronomers suggest that Venus could
have experienced a similar Greenhouse
Effect and had all of its oceans boil
away
and it wouldn't stop there as
temperatures continued to climb there
would be nothing left of our bodies
except Ash
the atmosphere would now be as hot as
1400 degrees Celsius and at this point
there would be nothing stopping the
oceans from boiling away
skyscrapers made of stainless steel and
glass would melt into nothing more than
a puddle on the ground
now would be a good time to cool off a
bit so how about seeing what would
happen if all the oceans froze over
well that's a story for another
[Music]